President Biden snubbing a visit to East
Palestine Ohio even as a community there
is still suffering after that massive
toxic train derailment but residents
have no fear Biden says it's going to
zoom in
planning to travel to Houston
I did a whole video I mean
you know the uh
zoom zoom zoom all I came Every Time I
Think of Zoom that song of my generation
who's zooming who
let me answer the question
I think Zoom is what he calls the train
fight and also dismissing the East
Palestine mayor who criticized him for
visiting Ukraine over his community
but couldn't remember if he even talked
to the local leader
did you plan to travel there and have
you talked with the mayor I I can't
recall I don't think I've talked to the
mayor I talked to everyone else there
multiple times talked to both the
Senators both like both Governors I've
talked to everyone there is to talk to
and we made it clear that everything is
available
um you know Danny you kind of made this
point uh or in one of the earlier blocks
I can't remember not sure I was
listening but you said that like
sometimes people don't do the right
thing because it gives your adversaries
the satisfaction can't admit this was
right or that was wrong in this case I
feel like we're in that that stage of
this cycle where like I'm not going if
they say we have to go it's just like
the Border it's just like the Border I'm
not going to the Border if the five says
we got to go to the Border we're not
going to go now they're saying go to
East Palestine that's why don't listen
to you Dana they don't listen to because
they they spite you I think they do hate
me that's true they probably have that
tattoo I know you probably feed them
their talking points it is strange that
Mr empathy though that his instincts
weren't to go or to send anybody or as
we've said before like why didn't you
call a cabinet meeting before you went
to Ukraine so that at least the people
of Ukraine would would know that you're
on top of it you're there and then to
feel like they're so disconnected it's
kind of also strange too going into 2024
I'll bring a little politics into it
because apparently that's the season
that we're in uh there is um one of the
Senators uh Democrat Sherrod Brown is up
for reelection and Ohio has been
increased doesn't become a very red
State and it's pretty interesting to me
that Biden wouldn't want to even go and
help him why would you not want to do
that the other thing I would say is that
Pete you know mayor Pete you got a real
death blow in the Washington Post
because he the fact Checker said there
is no truth to the claim or no merit to
the claim that it was Department of
transportation's trump ruling that made
this accident happen
so that that's a pretty low bloat right
there for them
Hera looks like the wheels are coming
off this train
uh you said during the break I'm so
embarrassed to be a Democrat right now
and I I and I said it's okay but it is
kind of sad that this is your leader uh
right he's he's our leader and I wish he
had gone sooner I advocated for a while
I thought he should have gone I thought
um uh secretary budajut should have gone
sooner uh I'm the the only person that's
been multiple times is the EPA
administrator who you've had on Nick on
your show uh someone's someone's showing
some accountability here
um for the life of me I'm not the
finger-pointing and the blaming I think
I'm gonna let everybody allocate a
little bit of that I think we got to
figure out how we help these people now
and how we prevent one of these things
from happening again and I'm I'm excited
and encouraged that the Congress is
going to hold hearings there on the
ground they'll get a chance to hear from
residents but more importantly I hope
they invite which it seems that they are
Norfolk Southern as well as other
railway operators to figure out what
they're doing uh in the future in near
term and intermediate long term to
prevent something from like this
happening again and then two
um what is it that they do to allow
their operators of their trains how much
subjectivity how much discretion do they
give them to stop those trains uh when
they hear the when they sense those
kinds of they hear those kind of sensors
those kind of sensors are alerted and
finally I don't know how much of this
toxic material we transport across the
country today this is an argument I'm a
Believer in pipelines because of things
like this but we need to know what is
the volume of this going across the
nation today how many communities are at
risk of this and what can the president
do I said if I were the president I
would issue an executive order uh
calling for all these operators transfer
putting this kind of toxic material to
uphold to a standard a new protection
standard and safety standard for the
communities in which this stuff is being
transported through absolutely you know
judge I think what irks me and I don't
get irk very often but I'm Earth now
that Joe was so pro-trained remember he
was always loved the trains love the
trains then one train gets into trouble
nowhere to be found guess it's easy to
be Pro trained when they're all running
on time huh yeah that's a great Point
thank you you know this is what I
disagree with Harold on he said
um he said you can't point the finger of
blame I said I don't I don't that's not
my strength well then here's the
difference between us I do okay
it's the accusatory part of the
prosecutor yeah I do first of all I want
to know why is Buddha judge ahead of the
Department of Transportation when he has
zero experience when he has no
experience at all I mean I get the
Victor gets the the the the point people
to whatever spoils he wants but this is
ridiculous why are you looking at me I
didn't know I'm just looking I'm just
looking I won't look into it I'll look
at the camera
the truth is only 33 percent of America
approves of the way Joe Biden is is
working on this train issue and for Joe
to put someone on that on Transportation
who knows nothing about Transportation
who clearly doesn't care he knew about
it right away I knew about it right away
all you have to do is read newspaper but
but Buddha judge didn't want to go and
then and then Biden as opposed to and
we've said this affirmatively sending
someone from the CDC or HHS you know to
go there and find out how we can help
they just say no you can't get you can't
get FEMA money because you're not within
the guidelines of FEMA you know have you
talked to the mayor well I don't know I
don't think so get your butt there
that's why Americans elected Joe Biden
because he allegedly cares maybe he
doesn't because they're Trump supporters
last word to you Jesse what should he
say
if he ever says anything
well it's not so much what he says now
it's what he does and he's acting like
you know those Rich dads that just try
to like buy their son's love
I wish
I would have loved that Joe's like I
just like I gave him whatever they asked
for I give him as much money so what do
they want I'll give it to you you know I
gotta catch the flight to Ukraine that
come on what do you want just get out of
here that's his attitude and the man has
no feel for the news cycle no feel and
that worked maybe during the primary
with the Democrats where he wasn't
responding on social media all the time
but he's the president and if some show
like for instance Jesse Waters Prime
Time leads with this toxic train wreck
seven nights in a row
and he doesn't respond until a week
after that I'm not saying you have to be
cutting edge like Trump trump was so on
The Cutting Edge of the news cycle he
was literally cutting the news cycle but
but Joe has to strike a balance between
kind of riding that wave and he does it
and this is not a right-wing story Rosie
O'Donnell has come the view is covered
that Jon Stewart is Aaron Brockovich is
in town I mean mayor Pete got hammered
on the Sunday shows last Sunday by
Network news anchors about this very
issue so
Joe has to say listen
I know what a zoom is and I'm not going
to forget about the mayor of East
Palestine and just get those things
right that would be a start yes that
would be a start very good all right I'm
going to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now